[Music]
what do we want to do I can just pull in
and leave it for a
second you know that is
very cool the deck of the intrepid
that's right I do yes yes I don't
understand fear I advise you help out
whatever advice namely space stuff and
some Aviation's I'm the space guy
you know it was a Gemini flight I can
remember which one oh okay but they took
what's what they did back in those days
and it is very cool to come to work on
an aircraft carrier by the way now but
what
we're gonna craft carrier it is for Ark
is really yes and as far as I know it is
no more live ordnance
shooting at us today but but yes so what
they do back in the old days unlike the
shuttle which we also have here which
landed on a runway they would they would
splashdown in the ocean and that was the
way they did it with Mercury Gemini and
Apollo in the so they hike it was in the
Pacific always it was you know always
being this masseur I think just the
biggest ocean you can find it's a big
white congressional land
yes you get specific and they would have
a they would have a carrier I like a
third of all Earth's longitude passes
through the Pacific I'm telling you if
you're in space Neil someone asks you
where you are just say over the Pacific
that's what you're gonna get it right
you were always a there's a lot of water
okay you see that planet like where is
the land you coming you hit finally
hitting man like Africa next thing you
know it's gone and you're over watered
okay a lot of water Pacific's a big one
that's where they splashed down the
helicopter looked like that though
that's a Coast Guard helicopter you look
cut it out yeah that wasn't that guy but
a rescue helicopter like that would go
pick the guys up bring it back to the
ship and then he would get ready to come
home so that's what this or recovered
spaceships on aircraft errors like this
and it served in the wars as a great
history here now it's a museum so it was
in a second second world war ii in
Vietnam exactly yeah oh yeah yep and now
it it's a museum any of these you fly
only one no no no I mean we got Blue
Angels here we've got an f-16 we've got
out this is my spy plane my sentimental
babe why is that airplane why it's gonna
fly so sweet it is
[Music]
still being used very the pilots it's a
recline cockpit the seat they're able to
apply me so much yeah you can sit back
he loved it the pilots influence
absolutely love it he'll keep him under
30 will fly if you should be afraid
you're gonna go sleep yeah no I think
this would keep you awake
there's only one guy to seeing that
airplane i from the t-38 we could take a
nap because you have two guys right here
that's the only airplane that I've flown
in on this deck because that's only
high-performance air
no I'm not I think I've known a minute
he's home hey I'm not a badass no yes
you know if you succeed for trainer D
for trainer the men and women that flew
these other airplanes went into combat
with these airplanes that's a different
story we use this airplane to train and
a lot of my colleagues who were military
pilots that's how they trained cliff
learn how to fly 150 30 in a rocket yeah
it's a train in an airplane right so
what we classify that training in the
airplane is Space Flight Readiness
Training so you can't go to space to
practice you have to do all your
practice on the ground in aviation the
Holy aviation acquirement working
together with a pilot copilot working
with air traffic control flying a high
performer it's the culture it's a
culture crew coordination necklace
emergencies of mission planning all that
haiji turns we did a lot of because it's
so little drag maneuver what's your
biggest D we went up to between 6 & 7 GS
it's just for just for a little blip
why yeah why this is a buyback it's a
spy plane and that's a fast airplane
that's what our airplane the t-38 is a
lock airplane but you would have to dump
a lot of fuel into the afterburner to do
that you can you'd have to be pointed
down to go Mach 1 that thing could prove
a lot faster that's really fast really
so what's your really high what's your
paper plane like oh the t-38 Oh real
absolutely that's my airplane it's a
wonderful it's a very maneuverable
airplane you can do all kinds of really
cool oh no kicks a man who does not have
any ordinance no asking abilities well
you can scare people but make it allowed
even the one
that's got ordnance yes and a missile
did somebody
push that one we had in here we had
luggage pot in ours we couldn't put it
let me check hard we had a pod
underwear yeah a snack yeah that's what
you have in ours yep we have a luggage
crud so it's not only national maybe
today okay it is also Mike Massimino
birthday it is my birthday yes and you
got me something from Chanel yes I did I
know you had that much of a budget it's
the world's only Chanel
I would all miss flamiel is that it's
too damn windy up here to light the
candle in these plastic
okay
happy birthday Mary candy
thank you very much thank you you know
there's no place else I'd rather spend
my birthday with you guys honestly